[Music]
in this problem a utility company wants
to purchase a new pump station the bank
has offered the following loan repayment
option the utility can pay $5 million
upfront and then make yearly payments of
$50,000 at 8% interest for the next 25
years the utility does not have enough
money on hand for the down payment but
offers to instead pay
$250,000
semiannually for the same period of time
and at the same interest
rate if using a present worth analysis
how much would the utility need for a
down payment in this scenario so that
the entity providing the loan would make
the same amount of money at the end of
the 25-year
period so this is a basic engineering
economics problem and fortunately it
even provides the keywords to search the
manual for in order to find the equation
we need if we search present worth in
the reference manual it will bring us to
a section called engineering economics
present worth has a few references in
this table so it's up to us to narrow
down the list of
choices the one we want to select is
uniform series present worth written as
follows so if we use the equation 2
p given a we would write it as the
following a * the quantity of 1 +
I raised to the
nus
over I times the
quantity 1 + I to the
N where p is the present worth value of
the analysis and a is the uniform amount
per interest period I will be the
interest and N will be the number of
compounding
periods so first we need to consider the
first payment option suggested by the
bank in order to figure out how much
money the loan is worth to
them we can write this as
follows so the present worth is going to
be the $5
million down payment
plus the yearly payments of
$50,000 these payments are going to
be at 8% interest so we can write 1 +
0.08 for 25
years so our n is going to be
we have 0.08 on the
bottom times the quantity of 1 +
0.08 also raised to
25 if we simplify this down in our
calculator we're going to see that it
gives us the
following 5 million hasn't changed
and 50,000 times what is simplified down
to
10.67 so this math is a lot easier to
solve and the total amount of money that
the bank wants to make is just about
$5.5
million I've simplified the longer
equation down here to the following
number just as a way for you to check
your your work during this problem on
the exam you could solve this out
instantly and just get to the final
number so now that we know how much
money the loan is worth to the bank we
can write out this equation again making
a few
changes since the utility wants to make
semiannual payments we need to adjust
our interest rate and our compounding
period semiannual means two times per
year so we are going to divide our
annual interest R by two while doubling
the number of payment
[Music]
periods and this time our known will be
the total amount of money that the bank
wants to make leaving our unknown as the
initial amount of money the utility
would need to put
down so again if we simplify down the
more complicated part of the equation we
get the
following and finally we can see that
our unknown value here which is The
Upfront payment
is a little over
$160,000 which would be the first
selection of the answers
provided so some of the ways that you
might get to a wrong answer in this
problem are as
follows the second answer could be
reached if you remember to half your
interest rate but forget to double your
number of payment
periods the third answer could be
reached if if you do the opposite double
your number of payment periods but
forget to half your interest
rate and finally the last answer could
be reached if you forget to do both of
those
things you'll notice that each mistake
in some way reduces the amount of money
in each monthly payment and so will
increase the amount of money needed for
a down
payment but again all you need to do in
this problem to solve it correctly is to
identify which equation to use solve for
the total amount of money to be made in
the first option and then back calculate
to how much money is needed for the down
payment in the second option and that's
it